hey everybody what's up welcome to
extreme Coco now look I've got my Friday
the 13th shirt on today it's a little on
the nose because we're playing Friday
13th with you that's right
you yes I'm pointing literally at you
follow me on PlayStation uh Blair to be
lui a ERT
as my gamertag and you can play with us
today we're gonna be having a special
guest stop by perhaps a couple special
guests I always say that nothing ever
happens but you know you got to be
optimistic in this time of terror
it's the Halloween season everybody
we're very excited only a couple weeks
to Halloween and only a couple weeks
till we start our team cocoa tour that's
right to polka presents Conan and
Friends a night of stand-up and
investment tips Conan O'Brien will be
hitting the road and will be hitting the
road along with him following along
documenting everything on social media
so make sure you're following us on
Instagram at Team Coco at Conan O'Brien
on Twitter Facebook on slash Team Coco
which many of you are already on right
now and on and on and on and we're gonna
be documenting every single moment of
the tour and I can't wait for Conan to
fire me on the second date when I wake
him up like wakey-wakey an Instagram
live it's gonna be fantastic oh here's
our guest right now it's I'm loving
everybody here tonight sound assets
gonna save you it cuz I put your water
right Todd lemon rider everyone writer
uh well say hello to the chat here we
got dancing spatula Andy mutts in rise
you Madeline Sims Hugo Lando Maneri
that's not a real name you know there's
no way that Hugo like log not owe money
Mon Aires or your real name I don't
believe you I just saw somebody named
dude not perfect
oh not perfect it early just watching a
dude perfect I'm shocked you're only
five minutes late because that's a
rabbit hole it's so easy to go down like
those guys love what they do
yeah we'll the bowling ball hit the
trampoline from the top of the dam
nobody knows nobody it will but it does
eventually oh that time you've never
played Friday 13 no I keep hearing that
this is a great game oh I'm so excited
and Beth what Beth was very excited when
I said
played it she was like oh my god she's
seen a lot but you played a little bit
once
is he gonna stress me out it's a hundred
percent gonna stress you 110 so and
here's so here's the have you seen any
of the gameplay do I need to describe it
to you I guess I've seen a little I've
seen people hiding behind chairs okay
great it's like there is a lot of
private okay so either you're gonna be
you're gonna be put in with other real
people you're but you also might be
Jason okay that's the fun thing you
might be a counselor Jason alright so
let's get going let's get going we're
gonna play direct all your amazing
questions about comedy and writing and
great fashion - Todd Levin you got great
you always a good fashion sense I feel
like good socks on all in your head you
don't look blood would you have last
night alright so hit X here we're gonna
get into the game have the cool go up to
quick play for now I Phi J sin mask the
future one Jason X it does I think we
haven't unlocked it I haven't gotten
very far in this yeah go up to quick
play if you would okay perfect
I do love when things don't work wow
this is fun oh it's search Oh because
we've already done you already by
searching I'm sorry that's Marty classic
Todd Levin stories is Biden 2020 eating
Thai food yes he's always talking about
food yep yeah that's right Steve 1994's
Steve 9s how long did it take to write a
sketch how what is the process on the
show for you have an idea until it gets
on the air if it gets I mean it depends
you sometimes you pitch something that
morning and it's on the show that day
you know you we because we we come in at
like 9:00 9:30 and sometimes to pitch
something you'll start producing it at
10:00 it's ready for rehearsal - that's
crazy on the air 4:30
Wow so time is you know your enemy yes
that's amazing
if it's something like fancier like a
pretty fancy Preet say like something
that require
a little bit of like thought like a like
a like a complicated pre-tape you might
have like the last thing I just did for
the show but when I'm hey this was this
T ad and oh yeah I shot that on a
Tuesday and then it aired on a Wednesday
well I was like a day
there we go that we still like everybody
works really fast the life cycle is
pretty quick yes because a lot of our
show is topical and even if it's not
topical we do a show every day and it's
a whole that demands things to be thrown
into it mhm
it is a it is a beast it is a hungry
mouth always someone said I was digging
a fashion up until I saw Todd's haircut
lol whoa first of all you shouldn't LOL
at yourself second of all you can't send
a comment like that unless it also
includes a photo of your hair cut your
hair yeah exactly look what are you
doing like that doesn't seem fair uh you
know let's see if there's people around
that we can play with it might be kind
of fun I quit my job and pursue writing
don't quit it
just pursue writing and have your job
there we go that's a great that yeah
that's a that's an excellent thing and
yeah the second part what kind of stuff
do employers look at when considering
hiring you I don't know look at your
writing sample yeah and then they'll
want to me give it to a writing job
they'll look at your ready simple and
you really can you go fullscreen
O'Malley that's the quickest way to
enter somebody in you is if it's a
really strong writing sound and if it
feels like it's the voice of the show
but it also feels like stuff they
haven't seen before
yeah it's that weird balance of familiar
and new and how did you for people who
don't know how long have you worked on
the show and kind of what brought what
kind of got you into the show I guess I
had no gray hair when I started is that
true yeah I had a full head of gray hair
when I started I came out of the womb
with a full head of hair that's true and
it's here and there I did some I
freelance to the onion
awesome and then but yeah it was mostly
there we go
there we go just like that perfect I
wish it were more complicated it took a
long time it was a long process but it
was not up I didn't have to go that's
awesome and yeah I think and kind of
everybody comes to the show via
different channels I feel mostly yes
mostly stand up or improv right most
people have that background because I
think those things kind of feed into
your skills throughout it because you
are constantly producing ideas so you
have to be kind of nimble in that way
it's not like we write a sketch every
six months right like everyday yeah yeah
brain to think squeeze and if you're a
monologue writer it's even more intense
yeah cuz they're doing just pages of
jokes that is a volume business for sure
hey a 1d 24 I'm dumb of course LMFAO
makes sense with the shirt I'm not sure
what that means but I bought this shirt
at the local Starbucks actually and then
I win it today and everyone kind of gave
me an eye roll and I was like oh that's
right I'm wearing this literally the
shirt
that's hilarious now I like to mute
everybody I don't like to hear anything
is that okay
I just I just what you like to hear
there oh I like to mute everyone because
who knows what they're gonna say on the
stream yeah yeah I'm not a big never
play online
everybody gets muted yeah and I don't
really I'm not a big online guy to be
fair like this is one of the only games
I'll play online just cuz I'm so
terrible at everyone else is so much
better
sorry fun with Don fun with Don I'm
guessing here in the chat I've got a
mute you bro sorry phones on you can
write in the chat though yeah you can
write in the chat why is he playing with
Jeffrey Dahmer oh is it because I have
glasses you know what I get that okay
I'm not quite sure all right all right
so let's go okay so here's the deal so
the map is basically a camp
at night some folk live at night now if
you're a counselor you're trying to run
and hide from Jason you can't you can't
you can't really kill him you can kind
of stun him and run away
there's temper you things you can use
them to get distance that's true yes and
you can creep around and the whole thing
is perfect I see we're on the lock
exactly you'll see very quickly how this
game goes it's very scary and when Jason
gets close to you [ __ ] starts going
gnarly it starts getting gnarly okay
and can you hear him getting close to
you the mute yeah the music the music
starts getting crazy and he can hear you
he can hear me it's sense you and stuff
yeah it's it's early it depends with
Jason yes some Jason's can run some
can't different weapons oh yeah it's all
good no I mean you'll see which Jason
cuz in the beginning he comes you don't
get the one with the bag on his head
haha oh yeah yeah then a little bit of
three that's the best I was a true no
actually he loses the bag at the very
end of two they take it off his head
after they think they killed him Tuesday
the 17th I haven't seen Halloween yet
have you seen the new Halloween no I
have nothing I hear it's really good oh
here we go
this is my favorite part every time
[Music]
yes we don't know yet we don't know oh
so now we're just yeah classic Jason
yeah with our luck he'll be Jason oh no
okay here we go
all right we got to survive okay this is
run just right okay so you can open door
you can open doors and windows you can
jump out of windows so you kind of hold
call it yeah there he and I could turn
on you could lock the door behind you
and I hold do it yeah so hold X to press
it and then hold it and then kind of
hold it
yeah all right now he has to bust
through yeah the other thing is he can't
he can't go through windows so one of
your big things is if you're in the
house or outside of a house you could
open a window and go in and out so
that's kind of a big thing yeah so like
you know what I want to hide so you can
hide under a bed if you want to no
that's terrible yeah the worst place to
be it's pretty gnarly and then you can
hold your breath and then you could find
weapons and stuff now you can find a map
also there's there's different ways you
can escape so you can find like some
pieces of the car and you go to the car
and I'm trying to just familiarize
myself of course yes you can find
weapons you could find a radio to radio
for help and the cops will come you can
find pieces of a boat to kind of fix the
boat and get away that way okay
I love song girls bleh had a crappy day
then watch her last Friday 13th bit on
delay I laughed so hard watching you get
beat up as Jason oh well good change
your mood yeah I wish I could jump in
yeah you can also just climb out
I played Jason and I was literally the
most bumbling Jason I don't think I
killed a single person everybody kept
beating me up at the end all the
counselors just came at me and I was
running away it was terrible
can I go through the woods here oh yeah
you can go through it yeah basically
it's open more it's a sandbox world
except there'll be boundaries you're
okay you'll know what it sounds bad okay
this is just hoping for more clueless
gamer Steve nine nine four Wow
we've kind of got a bunch of clueless
gamers kind of floating around so it's
kind of about getting Conan's schedule
and a big thing i Conan schedule is the
tour we're going on November 2nd
Washington DC we kick off our tour the
team coco presents Conan and Friends a
night of stand-up and investment tips go
to Team Coco calm slash tour - grab your
tickets while they're still available I
think there may be something oh yeah
there we go we're looking good we're
feeling good I think there would be a
crappy serial killer I would be a bad
serial killer it's too loud I'm some way
too loud pretty clumsy I think Jose
Arroyo one of our writers wrote a really
funny sketch years ago that one is one
of my favorites which is we see the
thing a late night called
satellite TV channels and one of them he
wrote and also started was the
anal-retentive no is OCD home invasion
or OCD serial killer yeah something like
that and so it's a woman in a bed and he
comes in and Jose's got these big
glasses he's a guy he's got a knife he's
coming in and he's got shuts door behind
him the bedroom area comes in and he
goes and he kind of steps back and he
makes sure the door's locked
and he goes I'm gonna get and then he's
like he just wants to check the door
again and then it just it devolves into
him just getting yeah yeah he just he's
keeps locking the door and making sure
it's locked she's like uh and then
eventual I think just leave and he's
like so looking at the door she gets
bored with it's one of my favorite
sketches of all time
also Jose played it so well it's really
great I don't know that looks like it's
take another room yeah so yeah we're
kind of looking for we could find try
and find a map we could try to find me I
know you got an axe man you could try
and find oh no now he's closed that
musical oh you got no gun yes when you
hear this music
that means he's kind of coming from
dairies on the map over there oh he's in
the water here okay
mr. charger says do you guys play a day
dead by daylight I don't like that game
as much that music means he's slightly
close oh that's good get the map this is
good no it's gonna show us where the car
is though do you want to hit this center
he's I feel like he's close to you know
myself oh I think he ran away oh he did
like a weird more things I heard because
the music is that you only have one shot
though just you know are you kind of
like can hack of a way but I think the
shot gets better will there be any
discount tickets that's a good question
I don't know better discount tickets I'm
not sure I don't think so you can also
watch on all of our show that's a really
good comment he he did I think I think
he did maybe you could do a twitch
raffle for a color and fencing that
might not be a bad idea I'll try to set
that up
are there counselors who will just like
or dicks yeah I wouldn't judge about
your - oh I'll yeah
what are you alright here's what I would
do so let's look at the map quick hit
that center button okay so there's the
boat we can escape on or the cars those
two blue things
oh so somebody's called Tommy Jarvis
which is good what's that mean that
means like if somebody dies if they die
he'll come Tom you'll come back and you
can kill Jason because Tommy in the
Friday the 13th movies kills Jace you
see the little corey feldman character I
don't know I think he's more of it it
was like one of the camp counselors but
whatever if you find Jason's sweater
that was Jason yet we find Jason's
sweater and Tommy shoots him he'll die
because it's his Jason's mom sweater
yeah but the better way to do it Tommy
Jarvis is already there that's good I
would try to either escape with the car
or somebody's already got the motorboat
going so maybe head towards the boat see
where the boat is it's bad can you kill
Jason yes TV Ken you can only see him
sometimes on the map when he's like if
you guys mom's sweater it's possible a
pretty complicated yeah it's way easier
to escape
oh he's Cory's character just an older
version of Tommy Johnson yeah I see
I can't watch for head 13th I'm a big
baby Cory was a young Tommy Jarvis got
it Oh sometimes the silence is more
scary but I want to go to the water
right try to stick together yeah try
stick the other kids yeah I think it's
behind you and also all those white
arrows are where the counselors are okay
the gun won't war Oh in the water you
can I mean kids three you could swim and
you could swim if you want boy the gun
won't work in the water that's yeah
yeah he can he doesn't yeah he could
swim okay
oh man you're making a lot of noise I
don't like this a lot of noise oh god
there's the boat is he chasing you
what's that know that you just need to
gasp for the boat
oh my god where do I get gas for the
boat it's it's in a house somewhere we
can find it we can find it this is good
it's better we're near the boat I think
stay out of the waters his fat nut for
20 he hears you in the water
okay okay always listen to fat oh is
swimming drains your stamina Wow
everyone's upset we got in the water
okay we get it
I'm sorry we're trying to find a gas can
just for kicks I'm gonna that's a good
idea
why you do this this is that jeans I'm
sorry we were in the water oh we can
okay so yeah there we go yeah there we
go
I guarantee I'll step in that round
that's right the water inputs scream you
are why is there gas for the boat in the
house I don't know but there is there's
a lot of bad [ __ ] going on right now but
oh god I hate this music man this is so
fun to watch I know Newman I'm excited
I'm not playing because I'm this game
I'm terrible I can't come in through the
windows here okay gas and propeller
should be relatively close to the boats
as fat I mean it feels like he's close
his music is killing me oh my god this
music is crazy I mean he's definitely
coming hopefully he I think he more yeah
he oh okay there's so many running
towards the house don't shoot both
female counselors can steal Jason
mother's sweater so you have to be a
female count oh we're a female council
that's good
how is the stream and I we've all
haven't gone for a few minutes oh don't
like this music
real real beast acts says I'm level 150
and played on both consoles damn son
see ya follow ok follow Blair on
PlayStation you can play with us here
we're with Todd 11 right oh that's ok
oh [ __ ] she's really hurt oh no oh God
Jesus here oh god I'm gonna shoot I
think he's killing that counselor
outside I think he's killing the cow or
she's running her oh he's right there oh
there he is
oh my god I don't do it through the
window he come he's breaking all the
window so we're gonna hurt ourselves did
we jump out that's a fail is that right
I don't know what to do do we do we
should we get run out or should we stay
in the cabin
he's definitely chasing this girl yes
shoot her Ron says that jeez I don't
know but you know oh he's very close
that means he's very close all right so
we could either stay in here and wait
for the trap to get him and then run
that's what everything okay yeah that's
a good idea
he's gonna get you I'm too anxious right
now I know so I'm gonna get me
I said lepa yes you can we you'll play
in the next round did she leave no she's
here Oh God
Oh maybe he stopped chasing her yeah I
mean he's quiet
oh she left she ran outside I guess so
say on the other hand I feel like I
shouldn't go out through the window
though because you broke them right yeah
that's true
I'm very nervous about this move okay so
let's try to go to a nearby house maybe
the house in back or something to try to
find the find the gas in the propeller I
mean we need to find the gas so go to
this house over here yeah all we need is
a gas
I love errands nice Jason Mora's are
supposed to be nice I'm terrible at this
game
buy a tiger that hasn't been fed for a
few days and lure Jason the tiger that's
a great idea yeah let's go to the tiger
store you can go in the window though I
don't know if you were you in here
before no this game is a region-locked
yeah I can play with people outside the
States we've done that before so you'll
see a giant can of gas it'll be pretty
fairly obvious I just started watching
you had to panic attack I know I feel
like somebody's hiding in here yeah I
think so no Jesus no my god you were
your trailer
Jason magnet is near us oh my god Jason
just misunderstood he's actually a
really nice guy who wants to give hugs
yeah sure open your map maybe the oh god
he's close oh Jesus he's in the house
he's in the house jump jump oh please
jump
oh no gates break free press X press ex
ex ex ex ex ex ex ex ex ex ex ex now
he's gonna you can spectate players that
bloody lady
oh she lit my
[Music]
god damn it
that wild that's actually terrifying
it's terrified I didn't like that it's
very scary
well also because it was one of those
things where he just was suddenly there
I was just watching this the other day
oh really well cuz I just got the 3d one
ooh nice yeah oh we leveled up that's
good
Wow he murdered everyone jaw ripped
screwed murdered murdered cut open cut
open
oh that's fixated God sounds terrible oh
my god crazy alright let's try to play
some fans here we we played with before
he killed six people in 30 seconds as
Jason the Creator this game yeah it was
amazing like everyone's around the car
and he had that trident he was just like
oh my god he pulled someone out of the
corn broke him in half I think he
squeezed someone's head and like popped
out it was like oh my lord it was
amazing if someone just asked about Red
Dead Redemption - oh yeah that's a long
story that's a long story but yeah
hopefully we're hopefully gonna do for
clueless gamer to be super fun it's one
of my favorite games of all time see ya
it's so so fun I'm getting it I pre pre
loaded it it's ready to play on Friday
I'm gonna be doing by the way during a
video game on Saturday red bread
redemption yep I'm gonna make red corn
bread
it's a cowboy chili dinner - video game
- got calm go there and his mother the
first Jason technically yes that's very
case you didn't really start killing
until the first that's true that's true
I wonder we got a bear ski in the house
let's see what else we're playing here
yeah is that yeah you're right like
that's the kind of the twist somebody
put up I think it was the writer Katie
Dippold who's really funny I wrote the
heat she was watching for the first time
fry
13 and kept saying like she kept
tweeting like there's a lot of long
exits in this and like every exit member
there's like guy is like he don't go up
to that place and then it's like five
minutes of him getting on his bike and
driving away it was just she kept
putting all the alike of super slow
exits where I'll put this up to the
channel what's your favorite 13 oh my
friend rich says three is the best one
he's kind of an aficionado three now why
three is the first appearance of the
hockey mask I'd said there it was banana
isn't that one no meals are really good
so it's it's like it's a it's like a
benchmark okay okay I can't visit two
has the best final girl
Oh interesting okay I feel like which
one is for me I kind of like Jason Takes
Manhattan
cuz it's so insane that's crazy it's so
crazy
not even a Friday the 13th movie yeah
it's just like what are we even it's
like that that is the movie equivalent
of like when they added Yoda to Soul
Calibur what a lot in a lot of ways that
was Jason x2 although I like that I
think at that point I have to go but
honestly I have to go back I haven't
seen any of them except the original and
like the past ten years okay so I'd have
to go back and watch him now having a
couple years and seeing so many other
horror movies i wonder i would probably
say three if that's like you know for
all of those reasons I really like Jason
X Jason X was great I thought it was
like it was I was surprised by how much
I liked that way yeah Jason X was fun
for sure and also like I do it's the
scene I like to use next the same reason
I like a lot of those elsewhere comic
books are like the what-ifs like they
put Superman and like Russia or
something you know like I like seeing a
character that we all know and love and
fear in like a new environment is kind
of fun
this is they think three has
girl who interesting gets rekt in that
movie Jason I don't remember either I I
think um
I will say though I think that the
creators have done a great job in this
game of putting all the Jason's in and
really making this game really scary I
mean you know it's that was terrifying
what just happened with yeah it's it's
it's legitimately scared such a great
idea for a game yeah all right
invites are sent we're gonna wait a
second for the party to populate and
literally Kanye West no lied likes when
the Kevin Hart remote there we go well I
was just saying yeah exactly
definitely not fake Kanye West says
definitely not fake on us um will there
be a Red Dead clothes camera we're
working on I hope hopefully I hope it
happens it would be amazing I think and
also like one of those a lot of my
favorite clueless gamers are the ones
we've done and tied by the way is the
guy right Silla close gamers is the
open-world ones are always fun yes those
are hard to do yeah those are hard for
us shooting because you can't do you
can't repeat things if it doesn't go
just the way you want it you can't
repeat them but I think it's led to some
of my most favorite moments I think any
game where he has to spend a lot of time
talking to people yes other like non
playing characters yes like Witcher was
a really fun yes we all hate it
we all hate it with rarer which was
really popular yeah I feel like I have
to like apologize to which your friends
cuz we when we were messing around with
a game before yeah we were considering
it we're like this game is terrible but
it'll be fun with Conan right it turns
out people love that game yeah exactly
it's gonna be like a TV show yeah and it
was one of those things to are like
we're seeing that game through the eyes
not of people playing it but having to
figure out how to do a comedy bit with
it is the other thing too and so that
that had its own challenges and that
stuff so a lot of times when we play and
people have asked a lot a lot in the
chat what makes a good game for clueless
gamer and a lot of times I've said and
either back me up or not on this but
it's it's not the best games that make
the best coolest gamers yes because it
has to kind of hit a certain uh it has
to be like a lot of different areas that
aren't related and there have to be
things that we think would spark Conan's
interest and a lot of times that's not
always the most fun games right it's a
look
sometimes games would like a little bit
of sag between yeah like it Oh like air
between the different like different set
pieces different set pieces yeah yeah
that games with that kind of air in them
definitely is really fun
yes Athens really fun yeah absolutely
and like for a game for instance like
one of my favorite games inside it's too
tight it's too tight a terrible clueless
gamer but one of my favorite games in
the last couple years
let's play you know what we'll play that
next week for on Halloween for our
stream Coco that game was too scary to
do and place the PlayStation VR like him
so upsetting I remember the first time I
played it I just was tipped oh yeah it
was the most boring way to play a game
cuz I just every I took every step like
horrible is that has anybody ever seen
leprechaun the ghetto I think it's
you're talking about leprechaun in the
hood
that's leprechauns six three two they
just went stream yeah I have seen it and
I like it that's right a clue scammer
might be well the funny series every
searing YouTube there we go let's do a
big part sound Todd love and everybody
that's right
team effort responsible yeah it's Conan
really and then we just all right I'm
gonna mute everybody and then give you
the control here okay now we've got some
fans in the chat bear ski hello
we got a oh sorry muted you
sorry muting everybody phone with Don is
back read by nature what's up bard
Mohammed fard Mohammed yeah yeah what's
up all right here we go
please send a game invite to fat enough
fat nuts
oh damn honey could you I could try is
it - I think we're full could you stand
it - a fat nuts for 25 knots for 25
knots we get you in the next River
murder kill kill my timer to kill you
get all the buttons oh yeah why do I
seek on TV yes anymore maybe you're not
watching we're in reruns now but we will
be back with a retooled show what's that
there's no reruns but you can watch us
on TV ok calm Oh could be ok
baseball going on and Beth is a huge Red
Sox fan so direct your love of Red Sox
over to Beth over here hey that's right
Oh West Kitner co-creator the gamer also
had hand directing the creation of
councilor butts there we go BOTS nice
job of the butts you know what I have a
question how much how much work do you
put into the butts are you looking for a
little bounce how much and this is a
serious question how many meetings were
there about councilor bucks I would
imagine there were no but like but
specific meetings I don't know the magic
came up as a point in the meeting
perfect perfect that makes sense oh yeah
here we go
oh I hope you got a choke that guy's
always in it it's my favorite Chad
Kensington
the shears we got the shears and a
different upgraded hockey mask
alright survived goodbye alright here we
go oh yeah
all right here we go raining - that's
right this is gonna this is gonna
serious get into the light so hey yeah
let's look at this but let's look at
sorry let's look at that but ash
technique - I don't know
yeah what's the deal I mean there's a
reason for this though we've got the
guys creative it's the genre weeks of
but model around this perkiness and sway
interesting so no bounce but a sway
that's interesting I will say you know I
got a which male character has the
finest but yeah oh here we go let's
radio for the cops oh you can do that
yeah all right that means Jason is
definitely coming after us but we're
worth jumping on a grenade here oh oh we
call Tommy yeah oh that's close the door
bro
I didn't hear him coming through the
other door I guess the other person
didn't lock it that's why yeah he just
walked right in I'm also gonna open this
exactly see nothing in there I never
find any good [ __ ] Wes there's a path if
you only really see it when you put on a
bathing suit you see a slight bounce
thank you all right well you know what
I'm gonna say I'm one of the updates you
could have you know some of the dudes
and the ladies and do some squats you
know yes Wes you've been very helpful
well us what are some tips since we have
you in the chat what are some tips that
we can use to escape Jason and where
some other tips when I'm Jason where I
can actually kill a single person which
I haven't done what if what if Wes has
actually just lost his mind and oh
there's the gasps okay that's good to
know they've been trying to distance
themselves from Wes
hopefully there's it what if you find
the walkie-talkie from oh the cop
simonkal that's great so we got four
minutes and then we can that means till
the cops you can survive for four
minutes yeah well you tell me you have
to run to the cops
oh and I've been murdered right before I
get to the cops so it seems a good place
to get murdered I would imagine power
Jason to be hanging out yeah yeah here's
a tip with a spear behind it well done
four other doors you can play as Jason
yeah oh yeah Oh lock this is why I gotta
say this is like my go-to game I love
this game this is like my go-to
multiplayer game on stream Coco because
it's fun to play with fans it's easy to
pick up and it's scary every time it's
scary every single time it doesn't I
know all the ways Jason can kill me and
it's scary every time and I like it
better this is the other game dead by
daylight yeah if you play by Dale I know
the permit that by daylight is it's like
the map is too small it's too visceral
this is more creepy I don't play a lot
of horror games because I feel like I
have enough stress in my life
you know Oh oh shoot I got to do
something here we do our one whoops yeah
oh gifted yeah perfectly or something
yeah so it's when Jason's trying to
attack you doing this
oh you have to r1h to at each one of
those points or 101 oh it gives you a
prompt yeah oh this is uh this helps us
heal Oh
when we inevitably get although I've
never lived like a zit no cuz we have to
get the propeller oh yeah see we got to
find a propeller to bow to we're close
I've never been this close to escaping
one time um I helped somebody fix a car
okay
I helped somebody fix a car mm-hmm and
then two other people got into it and
ran me over as I was trying to get and
then drove away and then I got
completely killed oh yes another trap
that's great you know what I'm gonna do
can I climb out the window with this I'm
gonna put it on the dock so Jason tries
to get me good you know what every time
I get my hopes up though every time I
get my hopes up I get killed
prepared Oh perfect don't take the
[ __ ] boat let's go how do I get in
the boat drop that no no no no no don't
go don't go don't go no no don't go
don't go here yes yes yes no it's Cheech
is Jon Artz Chung all right let's get
out of here bro yeah yo Chong oh no oh
god no no no there no no no no what are
you doing now what's happening
where did he come from damn it in the
water I told you things were going too
well what did I say now oh no he's
screwed
wait how did he not get killed kill that
Chong is definitely getting it I don't
know he's dead oh yeah
at least Chong got it we should have
just waited for the police to arrive
damn it yeah you should have hung out
before the you just got nervous cuz
Chong was going to leave with the boat I
did because I was saying the thing about
the how before I got screwed because
that was fun with Don I wasn't no way
that you could like it the last me just
go oh my god alright here we go people
do when they're on trial you don't stay
in the water I didn't mean to stay in
the water was fat that say he got fell
in the water
fat nuts what did we do wrong that's
funny fat nuts said besides a fire
killed that drowned the drowning killer
my favorites best kill ever at least it
oh you know what fun with don called the
cops he said at least I called the cops
in time then are you fun with Don thank
you phone the done these guys are
running to the cops so hopefully they'll
make it probably not go read by nature
go read by nature's of the check I don't
know I mean he's a fast swimmer I'll say
that best girl ever under water for a
long time
you should've swam away I tried to swing
it when technically that first movie
who's under water for five years he's
like he's that's why his face is messed
up
right yeah good look in the Sicilian
living under water oh gosh
vanessa is all you can really do is be
sneaky don't sprint make sure you lock
all the big doors call the cops cut up
Oh No there Oh Oh see you Nate that's a
flare gun so he gets to gets distracted
thinking right away oh god hi read by
nature huh oh they're trying to see you
doing slowly so we won't hear him don't
let up dudes maybe he's just tired he's
just running like this
Jesus what's happening
I see adjacent there it locked the door
that's uh she made to the cops oh wait
just waiting I think for Jason says she
can rub in his face yeah there you go
although oh here we go we got Tommy
Tommy Jarvis
oh there's oh gosh we got it on dude we
don't know we just know for a second
West says Jason rules at improv
you know Wes you really made Jason yes
and stuff and we think we appreciate
that as comedians oh no this is a
terrible hiding spot Tommy yeah oh cool
they're witches although maybe if you
just hold still so is Jason you have all
these senses to you can do different
what do you mean like you can do a thing
where you all fit it goes all black and
you can't you see the red heat
signatures of some of the campers if
they're moving if they're moving out
even if they're moving like that's a
special like coming down sense there's
also a there's a great even more can fly
around it's like an evil dead
disembodied Wow
yeah but they all have different ones
you get throw knives and stuff each one
is a different ability yeah yeah each
durability Matt Hensley says his her
particular gamer was excited about
that's coming out soon for instance Red
Dead days gone battlefield 5 fallout
said he's sick
say about red everybody should learn
about red dead I agree so 30 I'm giving
up look I'm trying to finish Tomb Raider
oh wow just so I can you ready for
Shadow the Tomb Raider how is it I mean
it's to murder game okay I really like
okay there's a lot of really bad minor
character acting like when you're doing
health missions huh
there's a lot of characters who have
really weird because it's like they all
have here in like Peru but they all have
like very kind of American Disney actor
accents Oh interesting Cody in the
jungle welcome to should we end this
game just so we can play one more before
cuz we're almost done sure sure alright
sorry is that okay everybody I think
we're gonna end this game quick thing
Tommy is supposed to save to be a hero
he might have IBS which is fair enough
fair enough I think we got we're gonna
end this game just so we can like leave
with party just we can play one more
game sorry guys I want to get one more
game in before we end Jason could smell
meat you're a human horse you can okay
here we go alright quick play all right
[Music]
oh yeah I we did during a video game a
shout out the shroom Raider
we made stuffed mushrooms me and Eric
Willett Kowski you gotta come over front
of those by the way
yeah I'd fun drunken thoughts on Tomb
Raider that we keep imagining that your
whole place is yeah it's like sliver but
super sad and a dingy one-bedroom but
there is that Baldwin's sadness that
permeates sliver okay guys here we go we
got a sword man 9000 in the house here
we go big boy
lights out 602 got a mucus ari says I
was Jason Bear ski yeah their ski man
sword man sorry sword man 9000
though what yeah but yeah there we go
what's up what's up can't you just meet
up what's up what's up back at you there
we go okay there we go
let's kill Jason I'll be a woman oh is
fat that's 420 in there
dad that's 420 are you in here I think
he's just seeing he'll be a woman oh
okay yeah okay fair enough
I see bear ski 180 Jason last time
somebody isn't getting much advertising
people should check out his bio mutant I
never heard of bio me Thank You creators
bio mutant yeah you're good we're just
waiting for sword man 9000 to to join I
mean in 33 seconds it'll join anyway
okay that's right we want Conan ads K we
all want Conan again if you want cone
and go to team coca calm /to or great
segue to get some tickets for our
upcoming tour starting November 2nd in
DC and traveling all over the country
and a stop in Vancouver and of course if
you can't make it or aren't in one of
those cities follow us on Instagram at
Team Coco Conan O'Brien at Twitter
Facebook on slash Team Coco of course
and we will be following along like we
do with the travel shows how we take you
guys all over the world for Conan
without board we're gonna take you all
over the country for Team Coco presents
Conan to friends so we're very excited
and it's not gonna be a lot of sleep I
think it's just like it's it's chaos all
the way across we got Flula Borg coming
with us
who's hilarious of course in a whole
other host of comedians Larry Kilmartin
is gonna be a few dates Deon Cole Ron
Funches Moses Taylor Tomlinson who's
hilarious marina Franklin so a bunch of
our friends and I'm not sure there's
gonna be any investment tips but maybe I
don't know maybe we'll all be rich by
the end will be cryptocurrency aetherium
Bitcoin I know what's happening here
it's like the game might have hung a bit
oh there we go perfect we just missed
the opening foul but that's I'm gonna do
that
my butt's not great not a great but Wes
you skimped on my butt
also I feel like a white sweater is a
terrible choice oh yeah one of the
things so Jason was chasing you what
would your strategy be if you actually
chase the dream it's actually kind of
okay what would it be I would freeze
okay and probably Ernie okay just a
little wetness and then bring it up yeah
cuz I know that that's exactly what
happened I wouldn't be I don't think I'd
be very cool in that moment right so in
love of mercy don't ever play Overkill's
The Walking Dead it's underwhelming the
delinquent okay fat nuts for 20 of
saying put fat nuts on the tour fat nuts
how are you at stand-up or investment
tips can I climb this ladder I cannot no
I think it's broken
there's nothing in this barn this barn
stop sprinting okay okay at least he
doesn't glow in the dark space whether
that's true as Jordan ever done clueless
gamer know he has it he's coming string
Coco once or twice
Jordan is hilarious in his own way I'm
not sure he would be great for a
clueless gamer maybe to come in to say
some things but not for a whole clueless
game I feel like yeah do you know the
story of the TV story okay so I love a
Jordan story tales listen up everybody
so yesterday we had it was a trash day
very exciting world of comedy trash day
but kill this in the boat
god damn it Chuck get out of here oh
it's that's fun with Don hey you know so
we're trying to figure out where every
like there's a lot of stuff in the
hallway where
where we work where the writers work and
I mean I don't know I'm not sure we're
okay as long as the music's pretty chill
okay so the duck turkey no I don't why
would I why would I want that no okay so
there is a among the things that were in
the hallway of our of the floor where
all the writers are there was this like
this TV like this massive TV box though
we always assumed was was there because
we're supposed to go into somebody's
office it's like a huge giant
flat-screen TV five inches in the
hallway it's been there for a long time
65 inches that's here a huge box it's
been there for I want to say two years
Wow okay really long time damn and and
we're like what is his TV can we can
this be thrown out then someone said oh
I heard what happened I would have heard
it was the Jordan bought the TV and that
he had it sitting in his office for like
that we were kicked for like he had it
sitting in his office for like over a
year
before he even opened it what's just
sitting there had this like this really
nice TV that's crazy and when he finally
did open it this green was cracked and
he couldn't return it because it was
past warranty and they couldn't repair
the screen because the TV had already
been discontinued by then oh my god what
so he just had he had somebody on our
staff just haul it and hide it under
yeah geez is the stairs in the studio
where the audience is like a real TV
they're supposed to go to like Conan's
yeah it's just been sitting there with
garbage so I was in the process like
somebody took a picture of it the
process of writing a really long what
happened to this TV
they're all these stories about it's
gonna be and why is it hearing all the
making of a murderer like at the TV and
I guess Jordan like in in that time in
between it had gotten to Jordan that
like we all knew about the TV so he sent
out this email like there's a a plasma
screen TV on the third floor yeah yeah
yeah and it's the top of the line you
can look it up people at the time the
best TV ever made this thing retails for
you know people are selling it online
used for ten thousand dollars a crack in
the screen that I can't repair but yours
if you want it today so again he's like
somebody else deal with it I'm not gonna
deal with it you see it's just kicking
the can down the road kick you have flat
screen that's so man that's that's
Jordan thank you everybody for joining
us thank you - Todd Levin for coming in
friends are you how would you think
about this game this game is great okay
yeah good things about but I've always
been too free to play it actually helps
to have other people around
yeah bright lights yeah yeah it was
fantastic super stressful uh where can
people see you follow you on Instagram
Instagram at mr. Todd Levin mr. Todd
Lamar is tremble still are you still
online
I'm tremble I don't I don't use the bar
you don't use the blog and I haven't I I
got off Twitter because it was too
upsetting
i man still have my Twitter cap but I
don't use it it's just pretty much just
a hollow so follow me mr. Todd Levin on
Instagram of course check us a team coca
calm slash tour I want to plead Esposito
yeah that's really funny that's all it's
like my kids favorite song oh my god
yeah it's it's an instant classic
dismiss you uh and thank you for
watching we'll see you guys right back
here next Wednesday for stream Coco
Thank You Wes for coming in and making
Friday the 13th we like the butts we
like the game yeah wait a great son
thanks for not being mean
thanks for not being mean that's right
uh and yeah we'll see you guys next
Wednesday red bag reverse shrink okay
see you guys later